thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
White's men applying for RAF positions
are described as useless Sky News sees
emails exposing the pressure on
recruiters to push for diversity
ITV orders an external review into
Phillip schofield's departure from this
morning
worse than Chernobyl workers at a
Russian occupied power plant in Ukraine
tell Sky News it's a nuclear catastrophe
waiting to happen
Running Out of Time Boris Johnson
demands the government disclose his
whatsapps and notebooks to the covert
inquiry ahead of a deadline tomorrow
so all you can watch us
the golden generation inspiring the next
England name their squad for the Women's
World Cup
the interest rate time bomb that seen
some mortgage payments doubling and
cheaper products removed from the market
plus a new drive to stop all of us being
rubbish at recycling
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
a very good evening Sky News has seen
leaked emails to RAF recruiters
describing white men seeking to join the
Air Force as useless white males the
emails which expose the pressure to
boost diversity in the RAF revealed that
a number of selection boards to find new
recruits were canceled if they did not
include women or people from ethnically
diverse backgrounds defense sources say
the revelations appear to contradict
assurances from the outgoing head of the
Air Force who's insisted that efforts to
improve diversity did not discriminate
against white men our security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes reports
British Air power in Russia's backyard
these typhoon Jets Patrol estonia's
skies on a mission to deter aggression
but back on the ground anger is growing
with the head of the royal air force
over a botched recruitment drive that's
damaged morale and could have impacted
capability
Sky News has seen emails exposing the
pressure put on RAF recruitment officers
to attract more women and ethnic
minorities
one email dated the 19th of January 2021
from a squadron leader talked about
selection boards for new recruits saying
they'd been predominantly white male
heavy I don't really need to see loads
of useless white male Pilots
selection boards are how the RAF chooses
candidates to start training courses and
are a vital process to maintain the
forces fighting strength
but another email dated the 20th of
January 2021 revealed we've canceled two
boards next week due to them having no
female black Asian and minority ethnic
or priority branch on them I've also
been told by a source and Via a freedom
of information request that at least one
white man officially complained he'd
been unfairly disadvantaged by this kind
of recruitment policy as a white male
he'd been held back from joining a cyber
training program and missed out on a 5
000 pound bonus the RAF has since found
30 other white men in a similar position
my source says they're all being paid
five thousand pounds and there could be
many other white men also impacted
air Chief Marshals sir Mike wigston
denied any discrimination when he gave
evidence to MPS in February but the head
of the defense committee isn't convinced
and is waiting for the findings of an
inquiry into the crisis
on the face of it it does look like the
committee was misled when the report
comes out I will seek uh guidance from
my committee and invite uh Emos wigston
back into the committee to answer
questions and we'll put this very very
issue to him the inquiry was launched
after the resignation of group Captain
Elizabeth Nichol who took charge of
recruitment in March 2021
Sky News exclusively revealed she then
quit last year in protest at what she
deemed to be an unlawful order to
discriminate against white men
Skies K Burley then challenged the RAF
boss
and in any way do you feel that safety
was compromised by the fact that ethnic
minorities and women if I may finish the
question were favored over others
okay there was there was absolutely no
drop in operational standards no drop in
any standards there was no discriminate
discrimination against any any group
the RAF insists it will continue to do
everything possible to increase
recruiting from underrepresented groups
within the provisions of the law
at a ceremony this week the head of the
Air Force will hand over this goal to
his successor along with lots of
difficult questions
and Deborah joins us now live evening to
you Deborah what is all this going to
mean for the new incoming head of the
Air Force
well active Marshall Sir Richard
Knighton who will be taking over from
Mike wigston is going to be wanting
surely to distance himself from the
controversy that surrounded his
predecessor but the fact is he's been
very aware of the um of the incident
that happened that led the group Captain
Elizabeth Nichol to resign last year
I've been told in fact that his office
has been overseeing these payments to
these 31 white men that were found to
have been disadvantaged by the policies
of the RAF when it comes to recruitment
this inquiry into the resignation is
ongoing it will complete it will be
published and if it is found that the
RAF did break the law with its
recruitment practices or did act in any
way unfairly then people will have to be
held to account and that's all going to
happen on his watch right at the very
beginning
okay Deborah thanks very much
come on
after days of pressure ITV this evening
took action to reduce the Fallout from
Phillip schofield's departure from the
Channel's Flagship this morning show a
barrister has been instructed to carry
out an external review of The Facts
after the presenter admitted to having
an affair with a young male colleague
well Sky's Adele Robinson joins me in
the studio uh good to see you Adele
um it's taken a while for ITV to make
this sort of announcement that they're
going to have this external review what
do you make of that and is this damage
control now oh yes it is because this
has become a huge reputational image for
ITV hasn't it I mean it's become
apparent that as the days have gone by
as statements and comments have been
released both officially and
unofficially that ITV really needed to
do something about this to try to bring
the situation under control to try to
manage it and this letter is an attempt
to do just that not only does it
announce the fact of an external review
what it also does is highlight some
extra detail of the timeline of who knew
what and when now ITV have said in this
letter that the rumors of a relationship
between Phillip Schofield and his
younger more Junior colleague emerged
first in 2019 early 2020. it was
investigated both parties it says in
this letter categorically and repeatedly
denied that relationship I'll read a
little excerpt from the letter for you
now it says the ITV employee was aged 19
when he first did work experience at
this morning in 2015 and 20 years old
when he applied and succeeded in
securing a job as a runner on the show
he subsequently applied for and was
successful in securing a promotion to
loose women in 2019 he left ITV in 2021
and it goes on as you would imagine
given the social media scrutiny of him
we have offered him our support
throughout this period and indeed are
still doing so now ITV in the letter
said that it found no evidence of a
relationship at the time despite the
rumor and the hears say and it describes
its approach towards this as reasonable
and proportionate but there's no doubt
about it the damage to the ITV brand is
undeniable and there's no end to this at
the moment for the foreseeable because
not only do we now have this external
review pending remember that ITV bosses
are going before MPS on Tuesday yeah
certainly it's far from over for ITV
Adele thanks so much
to the war in Ukraine now and Stark
warnings over the safety of a nuclear
power plant occupied by Russian forces
recently we've seen residential areas
become the target of drone attacks in
both Ukraine and Russia but there are
now concerns that once again the
rhizoparesia nuclear site in Ukraine is
becoming a focus for the conflict Sky
News has spoken to two employees at the
site who've revealed a shortage of
qualified staff and an increase in
military activity they say it's a
nuclear catastrophe waiting to happen
both men still work at the zaparisia
plant and have been speaking to our
International correspondent Alex Rossi
who sent this report from Southeastern
Ukraine
standing on the denipro river in
russian-occupied Ukraine it's Europe's
largest nuclear power station and it's
on the front line of a war that is
getting worse
and according to two workers who spoke
to us on condition of anonymity and at
Great personal risk it is a nuclear
catastrophe waiting to happen if we are
talking about the worst scenario at a
minimum it impacts half of Europe half
of Russia and a huge part of the
Mediterranean the level of radioactive
pollution and most importantly the area
of contamination will be thousands of
square kilometers of London sea it would
be much much worse than Fukushima and
worse than Chernobyl these grainy images
show Russian forces storming the plants
last year
since then satellite imagery shows the
damage caused by shelling with each side
blaming the other
the workers told us Russia's
deliberately targeted power lines to cut
the supply of electricity to Ukraine
these lines are essential for plant
safety basic maintenance is also not
getting done
for repairs who can actually do the
servicing and fix problems the quality
of the workers is lower because the
qualified staff left so generally the
situation here is deteriorating
there are also fears Moscow May escalate
the conflict by staging a false flag
attack Ukraine accuses the Kremlin of
nuclear terrorism regarding the
consequences as with Chernobyl it all
depends on what the Russians do if they
are going to do it deliberately if they
have such a goal for example to blow
something up that could result in
disaster they can do it
we don't know their goals
the power station has been under
occupation for the last 15 months
now workers are telling us that in the
last few weeks military activity inside
has dramatically increased they've
witnessed Russian soldiers moving in
more armor guns and ammunition as they
fortify their positions
in August last year Russian military
hardware was filmed moving into the
plants there's now more evidence the
power station is being used as a base
ahead of Ukraine's counter-offensive
Ukrainian Armed Forces will not shell
the station that's why they are
multiplying the numbers of troops and
vehicles here the thing is one month and
a half ago there were two times fewer
troops on the power station and now
there are two times more which means
they are definitely preparing for the
counter-offensive
Russia denies its compromising safety
but the UK Ministry of Defense says
these are sand bagged fighting positions
on the rooftops of nuclear reactors
it is hard to know what is exactly going
on inside
we understand technicians are routinely
intimidated to keep their silence
everyone has their own story and I think
the most important thing is not to get
into their hands because it's unlikely
you will get out and still be the human
you were when you went in
the international atomic energy agency
continues to express grave concerns
about the nuclear plants and is calling
for the area to be demilitarized
immediately
there is no sign that will happen in
fact quite the opposite
Alex Rossi Sky News zapparesia region
spokesman for Boris Johnson said this
evening all materials requested by the
covert inquiry including his Diaries and
notebooks have been passed to the
cabinet office and should be urgently
disclosed to the inquiry it sets the
scene for a potential Showdown tomorrow
between the inquiries chair lady Hallett
and the cabinet office even though they
risk criminal proceedings if they choose
to defy her request well our chief
political correspondent John Craig is at
Downing Street for us certainly a
pressure mounting on the government John
to hand over this material and they have
until tomorrow afternoon
four o'clock deadline that's right the
prime minister is actually off to a
summit in Moldova tomorrow so he knew he
needs to get this sorted before he goes
and we all know that Boris Johnson likes
a game of tennis well the former prime
minister has certainly put the ball in
Rishi sunax court tonight with this
challenge really publish and be damned
if you like so in his announcement Boris
Johnson said that he's handed over
whatsapp's notebooks and they are in
full and unredacted and he's also said
in a threat what sounds like a threat if
the government doesn't hand over the
material to the inquiry he will now he
does say that the cabinet office has had
access to his material for several
months now that's not the same as
possession the access what that means is
that of course when he was using
solicitors provided by the cabinet
office they had the material but of
course he sacked them last week in The
Rao over uh handing over material to the
police so this is all getting quite
acrimonious there are those who in
governments who think that Boris Johnson
is trying to settle a few scores with
Reggie sunac but the pressure really is
on the current prime minister tonight to
hand over the material or face a legal
battle and there are although the
government's lawyers believe the
government could win there are plenty
who think the government could suffer
the humiliation of going to court and
losing a legal battle it's that serious
okay John thanks very much
the England squad for the 2023 Women's
World Cup has been announced the 23
women group will head to Australia and
New Zealand in July hoping to repeat the
lioness's success in last year's
European championships expectations are
high but the Women's National team is
also beset with some familiar political
challenges our Sports correspondent Rob
Harris has more
[Applause]
she's now chosen the lucky ones for the
World Cup so I
[Applause]
thought by winning the Euros for the
lionesses Serena vegman has raised
expectations we all have a dream and of
course we go there to get the highest
level we can and to to get as far as
possible England wants to experience
this again but this time without Euro
2022's top scorer Beth Mead an ACL
injury made the striker too riskier
selection for the 23 flying to Australia
ligament damage also denied vegman her
Captain Leah Williamson how much of a
concern is it the number of ACL injuries
particularly in the women's game well I
think we should see the bigger picture
in that and every every ACL that occurs
you need to have a look at at that
individual too because but and also what
what's happening in the pathway in in
the in the academies uh what the
scheduling daily schedules the support
for the players I think it's a bigger
picture and yes it needs more research
injuries present opportunities goals
have earned Bethany England a squad
recall for the first time since last
year and the captain's armband will be
worn by Millie bright who knows all
about lifting trophies but will this
armband be allowed after the lgbtq plus
activism was blocked at the World Cup in
Qatar and do hope FIFA will approve
Milly bright to wear the one love
armband and approve it long before the
Tournament begins I think the FIFA wants
to solve for two and I trust them in
that and I hope and I think it's going
to be solved before we start the
tournament this tournament will feature
Lauren James and Jess Carter as
England's only black players would you
hope this tournament encourages a
greater diversity of players to take up
the game and actually become part of the
sort of wider pathway into the ultimate
the lionesses squad I think we have some
some things in place but it doesn't
change overnight it takes a little more
time I think what the players did with
sending that letter and now reached like
access for girls in football in schools
that will help too but then it's not
solved for tomorrow and uh yes we help
every game so also this world cup will
inspire people
whoever you are to come and play
football you hope this will be the last
World Cup without equal prize money well
um I hope that that things are being
done in the right way and that is
equality and um yeah that's that's what
I hope for and I think we're moving
forward
so now we're really getting ready for
the World Cup ready with a squad to
handle the pressure ready to Take On The
World Rob Harris Sky News Sutton
coldfield
the bank of England's mission to get
inflation down could soon mean a further
interest rate rise and this could spell
ruin for many with mortgages already
struggling with the cost of Basic
Essentials people whose fixed rate deals
are coming to an end and those with
variable rates are facing massively
inflated costs our business
correspondent gurpreet narwan reports
the worst should have been behind us by
now
but interest rates are continuing on
their seemingly endless upward March
and for mortgage holders like Ahmet it
means more misery
it was about 790
per month and it's up to 1400
near 1450 now where are you finding the
extra money this is basically the extra
hours we work you know we're on a
contract and obviously we work outside
of our contract doing extra hours
how many hours a week do you work now
well we're on a 39 hour contract and um
we're probably doing double that maybe
more you know surely if you're working
hard and you know you should be sort of
ripping the rewards and uh and having a
certain standard of living and it's just
just not happening
Ahmet is not alone across the country
lenders are hiking mortgage rates in
response to Growing expectations that
the bank of England will continue to
raise interest rates because inflation
is not coming down fast enough
they've also been pulling products from
the market
a lot of these lenders May well be
temporarily withdrawing their ranges but
we are urging Boris to obviously have a
look at what deal you have right now see
you with your broker if you can
refinance because a lot of lenders are
pulling fixed rate deals the latest data
from the mortgage Market shows that
average two and five-year fixed-rate
mortgages are both now above five
percent their approaching levels last
seen in the Autumn at the time of the
mini budget that means for the average
household looking for a two-year
fixed-rate mortgage repayments have gone
up by more than 340 pounds in the last
18 months
and they could go even higher it's an
unpalatable reality but when you combine
it with soaring food and Broadband
builds as well as rising taxes it very
quickly becomes unbearable
many households are already running down
their savings and are desperately hoping
that things start to improve in the
coming months we should see food price
inflation slowing down to some degree
and if that adds up to signs that
inflation is becoming less sticky that
will mean that the bank of England
doesn't have to raise rates by as much
to slow the economy and bring inflation
under control
and that could mean mortgage rates Peak
at a lower level
households will certainly be hoping this
is the case because many cannot afford
for things to get much worse
go print no one Sky News
the former Vice President of the United
States Mike Pence plans to announce he's
running for president in 2024 at an
event in Iowa next Wednesday the former
Indiana governor who served as Donald
Trump's Deputy will be running against
his former boss for the nomination as
well as Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
and the former U.S ambassador to the UN
Nikki Haley despite serving alongside
Trump the former president criticized
Pence for certifying Joe Biden as the
winner of the 2020 presidential election
claiming he didn't have the courage to
protect the Constitution
and in Congress tonight U.S politicians
are holding a crucial vote on whether to
allow the treasury to borrow more money
to cover government spending if they
fail to pass the bipartisan Bill the U.S
could default on government loan
repayments with potentially disastrous
consequences for the global economy the
deadline is Monday
a NASA panel studying unidentified
anomalous phenomena better known as UFOs
held its first public discussion today
ahead of a full report due later this
summer during the session a pentagon
official revealed for the first time
that the UK is involved in international
UFO data sharing as part of the five
eyes intelligence group and the panel
chair used his presentation to explain
how a reluctance to report sightings of
mysterious objects creates a major
challenge for researchers
there's a real stigma among people
reporting events and despite NASA's
extensive efforts to reduce the stigma
the origin of the uaps remain unclear
and we feel many events remain
unreported
Now new census data has given us a rich
portrait of Britain at work highlighting
jobs dominated by older workers and
those with persistent gender imbalances
but there may be change afoot in some
areas at least our data and economics
correspondent Tom Cheshire has the
details
this is a portrait of England and Wales
at work 27.8 million of us the sorts of
jobs we do the sort of economy we are
and how all that is changing now by far
the most common job in England and Wales
is a sales or retailer system one point
one million people four percent of the
working population in that sector more
than 850 000 people in the care sector
third most common profession is a
cleaner or domestic assistant now some
jobs skew older we can have a look at
the demographics this is about people
who are older than 65 the highest
proportion is in elected representative
so think of a few hundred MPS and in
particular thousands of counselors
followed by farmers and exam
invigilators you need wisdom for that
and the data shows us how the world of
work is changing as well the traditional
industry like working as a typist has a
much older Workforce 60.4 percent of
people aged 50 or over but if you look
at the newer equivalent this is data
enters you can see this is is a lot
younger as a professor a Changing of the
Guard there we can also break jobs down
by gender now some professions are
heavily dominated by one gender 97 of
Early Education and child care workers
are women compare that to 99 of
bricklayers who are men 98 of vehicle
mechanics to their men uh with
constructions and manual trade skewing
very male but those gender splits aren't
fixed in stone they're changing too 75
percent of science research engineering
and Technology occupations were men
overall but there are more women in
Engineering in younger age groups now
half of female Engineers are aged under
35. you can see that so that might be
another changing of the garden other
audiences more female such as chemistry
and biology
guys Tom Cheshire there now are you
guilty of wish cycling this is the act
of desperately trying to be a good
recycler but getting it wrong leading to
potentially whole batches of waste being
ruined the government is going to ask
people to be more careful in what they
recycle but as Ashner hurinag found out
that's easier said than done
just when you think you're saving the
planet a staggering 84 of us are doing
the opposite
it's dry mixed recycling cardboard paper
tins glass simple type of things we use
every single day hidden in this mountain
of waste are items that are so-called
contaminated too soggy too greasy or
just downright wrong paper cardboard
plastic bottles it doesn't say wood
fishing them out adds extra cost or
sometimes writes off an entire batch of
recycling sometimes it could be an
entire load that comes in where eight or
nine tons is rejected immediately the
smaller bits we can't pick out smaller
stuff as coffee cups those uh you know
contaminated if it's a cardboard Etc
that we can't really segregate if we see
it we pull it out our job in the main is
the larger quantities whether it's food
waste nappies that type of thing and we
get quite a lot of it misplaced items
include Chris packets juice cartons soft
plastic bags wet cardboard and
toothpaste tubes which all require
Specialists recycle
okay his white households in England
will get updated guidance from the
government to clear up the mess that's
largely been caused by confusion rather
than ignorance definitely with that
question mark with that and no to that
would it surprise you that if the pizza
box had grease stains on it you wouldn't
be able to recycle it that does surprise
me gosh I didn't know if they had grease
stains in it we can't recycle that I
would just make it into an airplane well
now when I go home I'm gonna think
should I or shouldn't I misguided
recyclers do need a helping hand though
with labeling often causing a headache
for both Depots and households the
responsibility lies with with everyone
so I think from a government perspective
there needs to be make sure as clear
legislation guidelines to make sure that
recycling is as easy as possible so at
the end of the day the the final
behavior is down to to households and
consumers to to make sure that they are
putting it into the right bin
recycling was once a trend and is now
the norm with new guidance it's hope for
many more it'll become a habit Ashna
horanag Sky News
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
papers in the Press preview including
this story on the front of the eye their
headline humiliated ITV forced to order
Schofield inquiry will certainly be
talking about that and tonight we're
joined by the daily mirrors associate
editor Kevin McGuire and the Daily Mail
columnist Sarah Vine standing by there
for us join us after this short break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching Sky News in
just a moment the Press preview a first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive but first our top stories
Sky News has seen leaked emails to RAF
recruiters describing white men seeking
to join the Air Force as useless white
males
ITV has announced there will be an
external review into Phillip schofield's
departure but has defended its
investigation into the former this
morning presenters affair with a younger
male colleague
and the cabinet office has confirmed the
WhatsApp messages and notebooks
requested by the covert inquiry from
Boris Johnson have been handed over to
them ahead of tomorrow's deadline to
disclose them to the inquiry
[Music]
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire and the Daily Mail columnist
Sarah fine they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight we'll speak
to both of them in just a moment but
first let's see what's on some of those
front pages
the male describes ITV as humiliated at
having to order an external inquiry into
Philip schofield's departure from this
morning
that story and allegations of a cover-up
also lead the mirror tomorrow
the eye carries analysis claiming
Labor's 20 billion pound raft of policy
proposals would cost the equivalent of a
3p income tax increase to enact
meanwhile the telegraph says Tory MPS
are telling Rishi sunak to scrap what
they call unfair inheritance tax rules
the Metro reports that the former
Russian president Dimitri Medvedev has
described senior British politicians as
legitimate targets given their support
for Ukraine
the times reports that Rishi sunak is
soliciting help from turkey and Bulgaria
in his fight to stem the migrant small
boats crisis
the express reveals what it calls an Eco
mob plot to disrupt the running of the
famous horse race the derby
the guardian hears from the vice
chancellors of several UK universities
who believe that the way the higher
education system is funded is broken
the Ft tells us why it's soda ash which
is used to make glass could soon be
worth billions on the stock market
fun leads with a story about Prince
Harry the fact that we haven't heard
much from him recently
and the star speaks to a Tudor historian
who claims Henry VIII didn't necessarily
deserve his bad reputation
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
and we're joined tonight by Kevin
McGuire and Sarah Vine let's kick off
shall we great to see you both thanks
for joining us um Sarah I'll kick off
with you first if I may front page of
the guardian of course one of those
stories that broke today Boris Johnson
has handed over all of his WhatsApp
messages
yes so there's been a big sort of debate
over the last few days about whether or
not uh the unredacted two years worth of
unreacting WhatsApp messages uh between
Boris Johnson and sort of I think it's
about 40 minutes to the civil servants
various people should be handed to the
covert inquiry
um the uh cabinet office who are in
charge of these things say no that
actually
um a lot of this stuff is irrelevant and
a lot of it is private and uh the person
in charge of the inquiry whose name I
temporarily forget baroness
you'd like to see everything and she'll
be the judge of that so there's been
this kind of ongoing wow between the
cabinet office and and the covered
inquiry and and now I think what's
happened is that Johnson himself has
handed over a whole load of messages if
that's if am I correct in that
oh sorry what was your question Sarah I
didn't catch that I think I think
Johnson himself has now handed over a
whole load of messages yeah Boris
Johnson has disclosed uh all of his
WhatsApp messages today and notebooks
and Diaries and handed them over to the
cabinet office in fact he was um
extremely Cooperative uh in that
statement that was released by his
spokesperson Uh Kevin what did you make
of Boris Johnson's cooperation today and
you know seemingly it heaps a lot more
pressure on the cabinet offers to hand
over all the material
he did he's made them look Chumps uh the
ghost of Boris Johnson's returned to
Horn Rishi sudak and the cabinet
ministers yet again because he says
urgently disclosed Boris Johnson given
the lock maybe he realizes he hasn't got
much of a reputation to lose anymore
that nothing can really be there any
more damage him than we've seen and
Dominic Cummings uh disclosed some of
his WhatsApp messages I remember when
they fell out spectacularly uh Matt
Hancock's WhatsApp messages were made
clear but the cabinet office was in this
ridiculous position where it said well
we haven't got the messages but there's
nothing really in them anyway Move Along
please nothing to see here uh but now
Johnson's handed them over and said pass
him on I think they'll have to climb
down pass them on and Heather Hallett
the chair of the committee will will get
her way which the guardian quote William
ragger Tory MP who chairs the uh all
poorly constitutional Affairs committee
say look the law is on her side anyway
the government set up the Inquirer she
has a power to ask for whatever she
wants and Johnson appears to be playing
ball which I think is the right position
because he will be aware I'm sure that
if Hallett went to law went to court to
demand the disclosure of these no books
and WhatsApp messages she would have won
and the cabinet office with a lot so I
think the cabinet offers with Oliver
down uh the cabinet offers minister in
in the cabinet there a deputy prime
minister as lost and as uh egg on his
face Sarah I can I can see your nodding
is there something you want to add there
well I mean there's there's a there's a
there's no love lost between Oliver Dowd
and and Johnson but also I think that
Johnson's calculation is probably that
because these messages will involve a
lot of people including Rishi sunak
including this trust including Dominic
Cummings including Simon case
um that you know this if they're
disclosed that you know it may it may
help transfer some it will give a bigger
picture for him but also it may take the
heat slightly out of him because they
will inevitably have have said things in
the Heat of the Moment uh you know it
was very difficult feverish time kovid
um there were lots of brows and
arguments going on uh people were losing
their temper and saying things off the
cuff so it will you know it may actually
place it may be plated Johnson's favor
to have these messages
um exposed they will of course be leaked
I mean it's almost inevitable that they
will believe because and this thing is
sleep so you know that we have to be
prepared for that
um and and you know that was possibly
one of the reasons why uh the cabinet
office was so reluctant to let uh before
I have them in the first place because
inevitably they will come out into the
open and certainly what's that message
is uh people are perhaps a lot more
casual in the way they use them you're a
bit more careful about what you put in
an email let's see what happens tomorrow
uh let's move on to the front page of
the eye Kevin uh their analysis on their
front page tomorrow uh shows that
Labor's new policies would cost the same
as a 3p hike in income tax your take on
this
yeah I think this is going to be the
first of many stories on Labor's
spending program at the Kia stone or way
ahead in the polls what's full form the
next government looks like he will be
probably the next prime minister of uh
of our country and I think it's a
legitimate and justifiable to begin uh
scrutinizing Labor's proposals and the
the I reckon the spending uh plans so
far on free child care foreign aid
School breakfast and police tell about
20 billion pound which The Institute for
fiscal studies say is equivalent of 3p
on income tax isn't mean income tax will
go up three people that's the the
equivalent and latest tax proposals at
the moment really ended the non-gom uh
uh loophole I would call it and put VAT
on private school fees would raise about
five billion so that's a 15 billion Gap
now labor May dispute the figures but uh
we're going to get more and more
scrutiny Rachel Reeves Pat McFadden and
the treasury team have been pretty
strong on spending uh plans and uh you
know to the annoyance of many of the
company uh Shadow cabinet members who
want one feel like goodies to be told
they can't but those they have they will
have to show how they fund them labor
often gets this tougher than the Tories
um mainly because I suppose we've got
Tori prayer Tory press or Tori leaning
press but at the same time I think it's
quite legitimate that laborer comes
another Spotlight as well yeah so a
brief thought from you on this I think
we're going to see more and more
scrutiny um and crunch the numbers when
it comes to Labor's promises ahead of
the election if it's far easier being in
opposition than it is being in power
yeah and I think that's right as Kevin
says it's important that we delve you
know we get into the weeds of this stuff
but I mean the Tories have also got
their financial woes and the other front
pages that we've seen you know this
whole row about inheritance tax
um the vice chancellors complaining that
they haven't got enough money to run
their universities that you know money
is a big problem for both parties
regardless of who's in power
um and you know the the labor party are
going to have to come up with a really
cogent plan to persuade the public that
they can manage things better than the
Tories I mean the Tories
yeah there is a there are wider factors
causing the financial problems that ft
has got a very interesting leader today
about uh the issues in China and China's
Financial ways the whole world you know
China Germany is a recession the whole
world has got money problems yeah um and
navigating your way out of that is going
to be difficult yeah certainly there's
not much to go around in the coffers and
that leads us neatly onto the front page
of the Daily Telegraph Kevin uh on this
very issue of inheritance tax uh Rishi
sunak facing pressure to scrap it from
his own MPS
yeah they managed to get 50 uh or more
than 50 MPS I say pretty paternity Jacob
wrist smog I would say the usual suspect
on the right to the conservative party
uh to claim it's unfair they're
launching a campaign now basically I
think they were fairness with
inheritance taxes it isn't a lot higher
there's only some kind of a state's uh
uh actually pay it some percent of what
what's that about one in 14 uh an
individual can leave uh half a million
tax free to people that's really
something for nothing couples are a
billion pound it's a seven billion seven
billion is raised which uh Jacob B smogs
has a modest amount well what you're
going to cut how are you going to fund
that seven billion now I think it should
be higher George Osborne did say he
would raise it in 2007 and he helped
derail a labor or a general election
then that Gordon Brown was was
contemplating the 2010 Tory election
Manifesto said they've raised a limit
and and didn't did didn't if there are
taxes to cut it's not inheritance tax
because I think it's the fairest tax of
all because shrouds have no pockets you
can't take it with you it's maybe
graveyards are full of rich people but
it is a real welfare state you get
something for nothing if you inherit the
person who create that money is dead
they've gone but you are getting
something you're very lucky if you do
get something but I really think you
should pay tax on it and while we're on
this discussion of funding Kevin let's
get a thought from you Sarah if I may on
the front page of the Guardian uh Vice
Chancellor's warning that the funding
model for UK universities is broken
can I just come back to Kevin on the
inheritance tax thing very briefly which
is that it's the problem is that people
it's it's houses it's people's houses so
people can buy a house for very little
and then because the property Market in
this country is so mad and so insane
they can find themselves sitting on a
lot of money that is basically the
amount of money that their house has
gone up in value so if you have these
high thresholds then what happens is
people have to sell their houses and
quite often they're not people who are
wealthy they're people who've just
bought a little house and now suddenly
it's worth five times what it was worth
that's the difference the property
Market anyway moving on the vice
chancellors they're bleeding because
apparently they haven't got enough money
well can I just say quite a lot of Vice
chances are paid an awful lot of money
themselves some of them are on about
four hundred thousand pounds a year not
only that
students are getting the most appalling
value for money at the moment they pay
nine thousand pounds a year for as far
as I can see almost nothing they're
always lecturers are constantly on
strike uh you know they their
accommodation costs are Fortune there
why is a lot I mean there's this whole
route at the moment over some some
University finalists not being able to
actually get their final results because
they're not going to be marked before
they graduate which is insane I think
the whole university sector is in
trouble but I'm not entirely sure it's
just to do with funding I think it's to
do with mismanagement and the fact that
you know the vice chances are not doing
their job properly which is not really
just to sit around having nice dinners
with um subsidized wine it's actually to
sort of try and run these run these
organizations properly the problem also
they're crossed because they're not
going to get so many foreign students
which has been a huge source of uh money
for universities and you know that's so
that's possibly right because they again
you know they've used foreign students
as cash cows for so long the whole thing
isn't a mess I'm sure Vice chancellors
would dispute some of what you said
there Sarah but certainly you make a
good point um we'll we'll give you both
agree there and speak to you in just a
moment coming up on the Press preview
ITV orders an external inquiry into the
circumstances surrounding Philip
schofield's departure we'll be
discussing that next day with us
[Music]
foreign
and now they're going to be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
[Music]
would have been bustling with
today it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm Neville Lazarus and I'm Skye's
reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview and with me is Kevin McGuire and
Sarah Vine to review the papers this
evening uh let's kick off uh with your
front page Uh Kevin the mirror leading
on the Schofield row a certainly really
interesting uh what we learned today
about ITV calling in an external review
and I thought um it was quite
interesting that we learned the chief
executive Dame Carolyn McCall has said
has said that there's been a lot of
inaccuracy in recent reporting why do
you think it's taken ITV so long to
clarify that
well I suspect they uh we're hoping to
Bunker down and it would go away and it
hasn't uh not least because a lot of
aggrieved former uh presenters and so on
are sharpening axes and settling scores
and it's it's caption of public
imagination here so they had no
alternative uh I believe particularly
given uh they'll be grilled next week by
MPS to get an inquiry going and getting
a barrister is a I think it's a smart
move by ITV Carolyn mccort is quoted on
the uh front of the mirror saying we
feel badly let down because Schofield
admitted they he lied she said that as
recently as a month ago we've been told
no no affair
clearly the internal inquiry in 2020 if
that's when it was uh didn't didn't
uncover that he didn't uncover the truth
and you set up an inquiry it's it's not
in the long grass but you get some from
the outside or go through all the
records because we interview some people
uh and then we'll come up with
conclusions but
the problem in the longer term is you
can lose control of an inquiry I
remember Dominic Robb Deputy Prime
Minister said he was happy to have a
barrister investigate claims he'd been
bullying sold servants well found out he
had been bullying civil servants and he
lost his job
so it'll be it'll be some people
sweating in an ITV undoubtedly
Sarah your thoughts on all of this The
Daily Mail also leading uh with this uh
story tomorrow describing ITV is
humiliated on on their front page and
forced to order uh this inquiry
yeah I mean I think it's just
interesting the way the whole thing has
unraveled you know remember Scofield
coming out as gay and him being a hero
and and Holly hugging and all of that
sort of stuff and it's it's sort of
spiraled into a a sort of much darker
story really and I think that um
it's it it's it's about power in the
workplace isn't it and it's about what
people feel they can and cannot say and
it's about whether you can uh stand up
to somebody if you think they're doing
the wrong thing if they're very Superior
to you it's it's a sort of it's quite a
human story in that respect there are
lots of people
um in workplaces who who maybe do see
things that they they're not comfortable
with but they're too scared to say
anything because they don't want to lose
their jobs or because the person
concerned is very senior so there's that
that you know and and the thing about
Schofield was that he was seemingly
Invincible he was the the guy and nobody
could say anything to him
um and it does have Echoes of past
scandals uh of this nature so uh yeah
we'll have to wait and see what happens
uh I think I always think inquiries are
double-edged swords as Kevin was saying
because well a lot of them are sort of
in a way a way for people the people in
charge who should have been responsible
sort of passing a buck
um but also they don't always turn up
the results that you want
likely to be quizzed by MPS on this uh
Scandal next week Kevin what do you make
of um politicians wading in
given the state of Parliament and
political parties and there's an amusing
cyber saying that they also represent uh
represent as they are elected
representatives but ITV now go before
that uh committee it was a long-standing
routine it wasn't about this but of
course it's gonna it's gonna crop up
they can now say there's an inquiry and
they can deflect questions to some
extent if there wasn't an inquiry by a
barrister they would have to answer more
detailed questions so it's you know the
the timing is very is very opposite for
uh for ITV and I'm sure it's part of the
part was part of their thinking now uh
Carolyn McCall said in her letter to
which went to of calm and the chair of
the culture committee and the culture
secretary so they would share the
findings of this report okay sorry to
wrap you there Kevin I thought you'd
enjoy that question see you both in a
moment thanks very much
let's have a look at the weather